各位大家好,很高兴继续介绍多方安全计算技术基础
这是这一讲的目录提纲
首先我们总体介绍一下多方安全计算的背景
多方安全计算它最早源于尤其是先生1982年提出的百万封问题
这里有两个参与方A和B
在没有可信第三方的条件下
想比较谁的资产比较多
又不泄露各自资产的具体素质
只得到比较的结果
这个可以抽象为
双方各自拥有自己的隐私数据
想共同计算一个公共的函数
在这里就是比较函数
更一般的我们可以推广到其他的函数
也可以推广到多个参与方
因此被统称为多方安全计算
也有翻译做安全多方计算
英文把它简称为NPC
NPC已经在人工智能、医疗、金融等诸多领域
找到了实际的应用
例如机器学习、训练模型
基因诊断、联合分控等等
姚先生在1982年提出了安全多方计算的概念以后
在1986年又给出了基于混淆电路的二方安全计算的协议
那么1987年
格德瑞·米克雷等人
给出了基于加法秘密分享的多方安全计算的协议
那么上个世纪八九十年代的
提出了NPC协议的
各种可行性的结果和基本框架
那么之后NPC的各类公开的理论问题被陆续解决
可以说在2004年之前NPC的研究主要停留在理论阶段
在2004年
那么第一个基于谣的
混淆电路的二方安全计算的协议被实现
这就是当时的那个Fairplay
在大数据时代应用驱动下
那么多方安全计算
进入了高效NPC协议的设计应用和落地阶段
NPC的实现效率被不断的提升
接下来谈一下多方安全计算的分类
它可以从多个角度进行分类
比如说不诚实参与方的数量
那么敌手的恶意行为
敌手的计算能力
输入可达性
计算模型
通信模型
以及腐化策略等等
这些都是从不同的维度进行划分
首先我们可以按照不诚实参与方
也就是我们俗称的坏人
数量占所有参与方的占比进行分类
这里T就是坏人的数量
那么N就是所有参与方的数量
如果T小于2分之1
也就是坏人没有超过一半
我们成为诚实大多数
那么坏人过半的情况
就会成为不诚实大多数
在这个情况下
学书界我们通常考虑最极端的情况
也就是坏人的数量是N-1
T-1
也就是诚实参与方只有一个的情况
另外一种分类方法是按照敌手
它行为的恶意程度
可以分为半诚实和恶意敌手两种
那么半诚实的敌人
可以理解为它的行为是诚实的
但是它比较好奇
属于被动攻击
它会诚实的执行
应该遵循的协议
但是它会记录协议中
所看到的所有的信息
那么事后进行分析
试图破坏协议的数据隐私性
那么恶意敌手
它采取的是主动攻击
它可以背离协议的要求
进行任意的操作
包括发送任意错误的消息
那么从敌手的计算能力分
我们又可以分为
敌手的计算能力
它是概率多像式的
以及敌手的计算能力
它是不受限的
那么前者实际上可以进一步
分为不诚实大多数和诚实大多数
前面我们已经介绍过了
那么后者实际上必须是诚实大多数的
否则这样的无限计算能力的敌手
我们不诚实大多数的话
是没有办法实现的
MPC的协议可以按照输出可达性
进一步分为所谓的终止安全
Security with a vault
公平的协议
还有就是保障输出传送
Guaranteed out of the delivery的协议
那么所谓的终止安全
是至恶意时期获得输出后
可以终止协议
使得诚实实体不能获得输出
那么公平性更容易理解一点
就是说要么大家都获得输出
要么大家都没有得到输出
这样才是公平
那么保障输出传送是指所有的实体
公平私义就是所有的实体一定会得到输出
那么在不诚实大多数的情况下
我们只能达到终止安全
后面那些其他的就得不到了
那么在诚实大多数的情况下
理论上我们可以实现公平性
甚至可以保证输出传送
但是实际上设计NPC协议也是为了效率考虑
目前大多数的协议
只需要考虑做到终止安全
安全中方计算实际上是一种安全的计算
所以它也有计算是通过怎样的模型来实现
那么我们知道有图灵机模型
以及与它等价的一些其他的模型
那么在NPC里面实际上常用的一个计算的模型
还是布尔电路
或者和算数电路以及RAM成讯
所谓的随机存储机RAMDXS MACHINE
那么前两者是比较常见的
是大多数NPC协议采用的计算模型
那么第三种是相对来说教授
可能可以出现在一些数据库的安全计算的应用场景当中
那么实际上我们会发现
布尔电路算数电路
这些电路实际上它的计算跟图灵机或者说
我们现在电脑里的程序还是不一样的
比如说电脑里的程序它有一些条件的转票
那么实际上布尔电路算数电路这些电路
它是Oblivist
它的运算过程它是安不就班的
所以这个时候我们只需要把它的电路的计算的内容进行保护
而不需要保护它的电路的执行的它的一个顺序
因为每个电路它的执行的顺序都是一样的
多方安全计算还有一种分类方法是按照它的腐化的策略
腐化就是Corruption
那么攻击者确定攻破并控制差距方的这样的一个策略
那么前面说了实际上NPC里面它的敌手可以有一半是坏的
甚至超过一半对吧
那实际上在一个Game里面在这个安全游戏里面
这个安全定义里面攻击者只有一个
所以实际上大家可以理解为攻击者可以决定哪些是坏人
并且把这些坏人看到的东西可以都拼接起来给到这个攻击者
所以攻击者决定哪些参与方式坏的
那么实际上这个就可以在视线来决定
那么在协议运行之前就决定
所以这种腐化的策略就叫做静态腐化
Static Corruption
还有跟它相对的就是Adaptive Corruption
自适应腐化
敌手在协议的运行过程中可以根据它的需要
根据它的倾向来决定哪些腐化
哪些坏人应该
哪些实体应该参与到这个坏人里面
所以这个是随着协议的运行
它是可以在不断变换的
那么还有一种是分类的方法
就是通信协议的网络
可以是同步的网络
也可以是异步的网络
那么同一个交互人的消息在固定延时
某个延时内一定达到的叫为同步网络
那么安全对方计算的
按照腐化的异步网络的要求
实际上实要求
7是小于
三分之一
也就是说
异步网络实际上提出了更高的要求
它的坏人的数量不能超过总数的三分之一
那么实际上很多高效的NPC协议
它主要是考虑静态腐化于同步网络
这是我们现在经常看到的这些协议
它的假设
所以我们把它用红的框了起来
那么多方安全计算协议的方法呢
也有两大类
一类是刚才说的姚先生提出的
基于混淆电路的方法
他债用的带宽通常比较高
但他只需要通讯长数轮
就是说你发给我我发给你这个发的次数
就是长数长数次
所以他可以用在比较高延时的网络当中
那么另外一类是基于秘密分享的协议
他债用的带宽通讯比较少
债用的带宽比较低
但是他的协议的轮数
是跟电路的深度是正比的
所以他的轮複杂度相对来说较高
所以一般的我们是用在低延时的网络当中
才能更好地展示他的优势
当然这两个方法实际上他不是绝对割裂的
我们已经看到有一部分的NPC的协议
他的设计融合了这两种设计的方法
并且取长补短
达到了更好的各方面的综合的效率
密码学的算法和协议一般都有安全的证明
这也就是说是密码学像这种NPC的协议
区别于其他联邦学习等等
其他安全计算协议的一个主要的一个特色
那么我们实际上在密码学里面
会假设有一些困难问题
那么基于这些困难问题
我们设计出来的协议
我们就证明了只要这个困难问题是困难的
那么这个协议就是安全的
也就意味着说我们如果这个协议的安全性被打破
那么他抵达安全
抵达困难问题的困难性也就被打破了
那么实际上当然还有种就是说
我们实际上证明这个协议是无条件安全的
也就是说我们的公计者他的计算能力
不管是多少他都没有办法破解这个协议
这是另外一类安全的协议
那么NPC怎样来实现安全协议的这个证明呢
我们就引入了两个世界
所谓的真实世界和理想世界
那么真实世界实际上就是我们所设计的NPC协议
他们就是左边这个
大家
各个参与方之间他互相都有通信
最后呢
他执行获得了协议的输出
这是现实中运行的协议
那么在理想世界实际上我们想象一下
他有一个可信的第三方
大家把输入都发给他
然后他再把最后的输出发送给大家
那么这个时候实际上我们证明如果
如果我们可以从这个理想世界
模拟出来一个view
模拟出来的一个view可以跟真实世界的
大家看到的view是不可区分的
那么这也就意味着什么呢
除了协议输出之外
不洩漏其他秘密信息
不洩漏其他不该洩漏的东西
这个只是我给了大概的一个思路
那么作为境界阅读
实际上大家可以去了解一下
有兴趣的特别有兴趣的
可以去了解一下所谓的游戏模型
也就是通用可组合模型
那么这里就用到了模块化的思想来设计
更为复杂的安全协议
他可以把协议拆分成若干的
若干个紫部分
如果我们每个紫部分都具有
所谓的游戏安全的一个性质
那么这些协议组合起来
他也是安全的
关于NPC的分类和国内外最新的研究进展
大家可以去参考下面几篇论文
相对来说是比较新的中数的论文
第一篇就是领调的一个在2021年发表的一个中数
那么还有
还有就是最后一个的
是我们国家核能国院士和阳抗研究员
最新的一个关于NPC的一个中数
另外要从头到尾开始学习NPC的话
有一些推荐的书籍
第一个比较推荐的就是说
实用安全多方计算导论
它属于NPC它的入门的书籍
那么还有就是
Applications of Secure Multi-Party Computation
这么说它介绍了NPC的基本构造和应用
那么最后一个相对来说更老一点
就是Efficient Secure 2-Party Protocols
它主要介绍安全二方计算的安全模型协议
以及它底层的一些密码组件
大家有兴趣可以去看一下了解一下
那么另外还有更多的一些教材
就包括Odder the Godric
在它的经典的密码学基础这个教材的第二卷里面
第七章介绍了NPC的模型和部分的技术基础
但它这个首先它的这个书是比较老了
另外它的描述是比较绘色
它的讲的东西不是那么友好
那么此外还有Secure Multi-Party Computation
这本书是从secure sharing的
是从秘密分享的角度来介绍NPC的
那么另外我们Eprint上面也有一个关于
秘密分享NPC的入门的教材
最右边的这个是经典出版
接下来我们就介绍一下基于混淆电路的NPC
因为我们前面说了NPC大概有两大技术路线
第一个就是姚先生提出的
基于混淆电路的这个方法
那混淆电路是设计长素人NPC协议的一个基础的组件
有姚先生在1986年提出
但实际上他当时并没有把这个写在他的发表的论文集里面
他只是在一个会议上口头上做了个介绍
那么后人对他的这个方法进行了一些细化
进行了一些安全性的分析
比如2012年比较等人为混淆电路
给出了形式化的安全定义
以及具体的安全性的分析
并且对协议的具体的实力化等技术细节
也做了进一步的产数
那么实际上混淆电路的这个混淆方案
可以理解为有四个算法
首先它是有一个GABO算法
GABO算法的话就是说
它把我们要计算的电路
而计算的这个函数它对应的电路C作为输入
那么作为输出它可以输出三样东西
第一个是GC
就是被混淆的电路
它是GABO的涉及的缩写
那么还有就是编码信息和编码信息
那么这个时候我们如果把我们的输入的
输入的X放到这个另外一个算法
InCode里面
那么再根据刚才说的那个编码信息
我们就可以把这个输入这个小X
可以理解为加密或者老乱成一个大X
就是加密后的输入
那么这时候我们还有一个Evaluation算法
Evaluation算法就是说把刚才那个混淆
或者电路GC
以及编码或者加密后的这个输入大X
这两个作为输入
然后输出一个
可以理解为是加密后的输出Y
或者说加密后的计算结果Y
那么这个时候我们要把大Y解密出来
就需要用到一个Decode的算法
Decode的算法它的输入有两个
一个是我们的加密的输出Y
另外一个就是刚才我们说的解码信息D
这样的话呢
Decode的输出就是一个最终的计算结果的明文
小Y等于CX
这就是一个混淆电路它的一个大致上的一个概念
接下来我们来介绍一下混淆电路的现有的方案
和它对应的这些性能
那么我们可以理解为混淆电路是一个加密
电路的加密的一个方法
所以实际上它就是对应了密文的大小
因为实际上我们在NPC的协议里面需要把混淆以后的电路发来发去
所以每一个门 每一个逻辑门 羽门和异祸门
它密文的大小就对应了这个协议的通讯的效率
这里面我们有个安全参数
就是这里的K Kappa实际上读为Kappa
那么可以理解为这个就是密要的长度
那么在没有优化的
没有优化的就是姚先生当年提出的那个协议里面
他的羽门和异祸门的通讯可能都要达到8个Kappa
那么通过Point and Permit这个点资换的方法
实际上我们可以把这个压缩到4个Kappa
每个门都是4个Kappa
那么之后出现了很多重要的优化改进的混淆电路的构造方法
我们看到实际上当我们出现Free XOR的时候
这个异祸门它的通讯变为了0
这就是为什么叫Free XOR
那么最新的一个工作实际上是去年的
我们把这个通讯门不仅可以用到Free XOR的门的通讯降为0
同时我们的羽门的通讯也大概降到了1.5Kappa左右
这就是刚才我们说的已知的混淆电路构造中
最重要的也就是目前最先进的混淆电路的技术主要是这三个
那么对异祸门进行混淆的话就是Free XOR
它可以实现异祸门的混淆是免费的
是不占用密闻或者不占用通讯
那么同时与它可以兼容的一个人就是叫Halfgate-Bam
Bam就是说将羽门或者说一些其他的一个非线性门
它可以降低到两倍安全参数的长度的密闻
那么当然最新的当然就是刚才我说的去年的叫3Half
它可以将羽门的加密或者密闻降低到1.5Kappa
1.5倍的安全长度
NPC里面还经常用到一个纸协议叫不经意传输
英文叫Oblivis Transfer 简称叫OT
那么实际上就是最左边这个OT
它实际上说有个发送方有个接收方
左边是发送方右边是接收方
发送方有两个消息M0和M1
那么接收方它有个选择
它的输入就是选择B
它可以是零和或者E
它从发送方的两个消息里面
选一个最终得到了MB
那么这里的安全要求是说
发送方它不能知道接收方它最后选择了哪一个
也就是说发送方它不能知道对方拿了哪个B
那么接收方它只能从在发送方的两个消息里面
挑一个而不能两个都得到
那么这就是OT
那么OT实际上还有一些变形
比如说是ROT
就随Random的OT
那么它与OT的功能是基本上是相同的
但是呢
就是说这里看到大家看到
只是说做了一些随机化
就是说消息是随机的
这个选择也是随机的
选择不是
不是这个接收方选的
是它是随机选的
那么还有一个就是非常相关的
就叫COT相关性的OT
那么相关性的OT实际上也是另外一种变形
除了跟ROT是相同
但是你看大家看到这个两个消息
R0和R1它是满足一个相关性的
就是R0和R1它之间的异货或者它的offset是delta
那这里的delta
你可以就会是一个
是一个global的一个东西
你不光这里的R0和R1是一个delta
在其他地方很多
其他OT协议里面发的消息
它的差异也是delta
所以它是一个相关性的一个
满足相关性的一个消息
所以最终接收方
它会得到R0异货上B乘以delta
就是B是它自己的输入
是接收方的输入
那么我们其实已经知道
这些方案实际上是相对来说
是我们可以把COT转换成ROT
最终转换成我们需要使用的OT
所以它们这些协议在功能上都等价于OT
很多的NPC协议实际上需要大量的OT
而不是说也几个或者说几十个
那么基于公要密码的OT
它的协议的开销是非常大的
我们知道公要密码实际上
它的一个劣势相对于delta密码
就是它的计算效率比较差
所以我们要生成大量的OT的话
如果都用公要密码去生成的话
是非常慢的
那么为了解决这个问题
实际上提出了一个概念叫OT extension
OT扩展
那么通过一些快速的操作
将少量基于公要密码得到的OT
扩展得到大量
就是大量就是说多像是个数量的OT
那么最早的一个OT的扩展协议叫
IKMP类的一个协议
那么最近几年的实际上
这个OT的扩展这些方法
实际上得到了进一步的发展
不经意传输它的另外一类扩展
实际上可以叫做PCG和PCF
所谓的Piece of the random correlation generator
尾随机的相关性的生成器
和尾随机相关性的生成函数
尾随机性相关的生成函数
那么前者的话
它实际上这里的话
PCF类的协议
实际上它比PCG的协议相对来说
是较效率更低一点
PCG它通讯量小
可以达到一些信息负达度
PCF可能比较差一点
那PCG协议它也有它的缺点
就说它的计算量比较大
而且它需要一次性计算所有的输出
这就是说这跟PRG是一样的
尾随机生成器它也需要一支输出
输出所有的输出
那么作为PCF它是个函数
所以它可以按P次的计算
所需要的按我们的需求计算输出
目前来说实际上
当我们需要几百几千个OT的时候
还是用前面所说的
IKNP类的OT extension效率比较高
但是当我们需要上万个
甚至更多的OT的时候
我们使用PCG这一类的协议
效率会更高一点
不经意传输还可以推广到一个更大的预算
我们称为是不经意线性函数计算
Orbalific Linear Evaluation
那么实际上
就是右边我们把它简称OLE
这个时候可以发送方
它可以定义一个访设函数
Fine Function
那么实际上是定义这个访设函数的两个参数
那么接收方给一个输入
然后接收方就得到访设函数的输出
那么这里的元素都是在某个大域上面的
那么当然OLE这里面
可以套到一个用途
是可以用来生成
惩罚的原主
比如说双方都输入一个XY
他们最后在这里
我们右边这个图上表示的
实际上最后双方就得到了X乘完的
X乘完的它的一个加分分享
那么另外一个协议是
相量不经意线性函数
叫所谓的ViewLE
我们在OLE前面加了一个V
表示Vector
这里面Delta是一个预算的元素
但是V,EU,W都是一个相量
那么这里的它的主要的用途
是用来认证预算,认证预算元素
下面的话我们给出了各个协议的比较
用不同方法来构造的协议
它的构造的方法
它的通讯的复杂度
以及它的安全假设是怎样的
这里面比特分解它比同态加密
通讯量更大
但它计算得更快
所以它们两个是各有优劣
所以到其实这里同态加密的方法
我们用到的假设是LWE
那么PCG和PCF
它们用到的安全假设都是LPN
那么这里实际上LPN和LWE
我们可以认为它是一个
耗量值安全的一个假设
是可以对抗量值计算机的攻击者
在我们了解完那个混淆电路算法
以及OT不经意传输以后
我们现在可以来描述一下
谣的二方安全计算的协议的框架
假设这双方都是一个
三面honest半成式的一个差距方
这个时候呢
差距方假左边的这个人
我们把它称为gabra
它就把他们要计算的这个
函数所对应的电路
通过gabra算法
把它混淆成一个
混淆的电路GC以及它的编码信息
E和解码信息D
那么在理解阶段
也就是说在双方都不知道
要计算什么输入的时候
它就可以把这个混淆电路发过去
同时呢
后面可以gabra可以把它的输入的编码
因为它的输入是小X
它通过这个E
小E进行编码就变成大X
并且它就可以把它的
加密以后的输入
大X以及解码信息D发过去
那这是个evaluate
它有自己的输入
小Y
它需要通过执行这个OT协议
因为它不知道
它这个小Y
它每一个比特
它对应了哪一个输入
哪一个加密的输出
所以它执行这个OT协议
就得到它的输入
它加密以后的只Y
大Y
那么这个时候
它可以运行这个evaluation算法
evaluation算法
把混淆电路
以及加密以后的输入输出
加密以后双方的输入
大X和大Y
然后作为输出
它得到了一个加密以后的计算结果
大Z
这个时候我们再调用Decode的算法
再把解码信息作为输入
以及把大Z作为输入
得到最后的计算结果
小Z
它就等于C XY
那当然它这个时候
它得到了这样一个输出
它可以把输出也告诉左边
这里假设大家都是一个三秒Honest
那么当然这个
当然只是说给出了一个大字的过程
那么大家其实有兴趣的话
可以去看一下
现有的一些谎销电路的方案
以及怎样基于这些方案
我们如何来给出
谣的这个二方
二方安全计算协议
在半成是模型销的安全性的证明
这个就留作大家课后的一个练习
前面介绍的这个谣的
二方安全计算的这个协议
是在半成是模型下面的
提升模型下面
也就是说这工记者他不会
他必须老老实实的遵循协议
那么如何证明
如何实现
如何实现这些在恶意地手下
二方计算的协议的安全性
那么这个时候呢
需要加入一些额外的手段
比如说我们如何检测
左边这位Gabler的恶意行为
因为他可以准备一个恶意的
不是不正确的一个红桥电路
来实现他的某种破坏隐私的目的
那么这里呢
就是一种比较传统经典的方法
比较cut and choose CNC
那么实际上这里有两种
有两种类型一种是电路级别的
就是他可以Gabler
他可以准备多个GC
多个GC发送给发送给
右边的这个
evaluate
对吧
右边这位参与方
那么参与方他拿到GC以后
他可以
他可以随机选择
从这个发送的这个GC里面
那么多GC里面
要求他打开
要求发送方打开其中的一半的GC
进行检查
进行证确性的检查
如果这个GC是错误的
这个是恶意
恶意
他没有正确的进行Gabler
那么这个协议执行就结束了
并且这个发送Gabler的
他的恶意的行为就被发现了
如果没有被发现
如果发现这些打开的一半都是正确的
那么我们把剩下来的
用于计算
并且我们把这种
所计算的值取一个
投票
取一个最终的一个值
那么还有一种就是CNC
也就是蒙级的
蒙级的Katantius
这个时候呢我们需要
计算N个混淆的与门
随机一半打开检查
将剩下的一半
混淆门
混淆的按的电路
贴合
粘合成一个
粘合成一个GC
所以这个是两种
两种不同的实现方法
实际上前面说的Katantius
已经不是实现2ED手模型下的
2PC协议的最优的方法
当前技术的我们可以
采用认证混淆电路的方法
Occentricated Gablering的方法
那么实际上他的
思想就是说我们可以通过
信息论
消息认证
IT Mac
就是这个是
这个是密码宣传里面的一个组件
它是可以来做一个消息认证
它可以实现
信息论意义上的安全性
但是它只能
它只能一个key只能用一次
那么实现
电路的认证
保证
计算的结果的证券性
那么同时呢我们又可以通过
混淆电路的分布式生成
来抵抗
选择性失败攻击
Selective Failure Attack
因为实际上第一手它可以
它可以释出来猜测
里面的部分比特
那么如果他发现这个
猜测的比特是对的
那么可能这个协议就不会终止了
如果他猜测错误了
可能就是协议是终止了
这样的话呢
我们
这个协议可以分为三个阶段
第一个阶段是
电路无关
预处理
就是说这个
当我们的电路都不知道的时候
实际上我们可以生成这些
随机的
认证
认证的三元组
和IT Mac
那么在电路
但我们要计算什么电路
知道的时候
实际上我们可以进行
极其的分布式的生成
最后在在线阶段
当大家的输入都是已知的时候
我们可以来
大家共同来计算混淆电路
以获得
电路的输出
最后的结果的输出
在这方面
其实有一些相关的
相关的论文大家有兴趣
可以关注一下
目前主要有两种
分布式混淆电路的构造
分别是BNR和WRK
那么BNR它是属于对称的
对称型的
就所有参与方都能参与计算极其
那么WRK它是非对称的
只有指定的
指定的一方可以计算混淆电路
他们的通讯带宽和在线的轮速
略有不同
这里给出了
他们这两个的比较
以及相关的一些
paper
大家可以看一下
比如混淆电路方法
像并行的另外一类
NPC的协议
实现方法
是基于秘密分享的方法
什么是秘密分享
那么实际上最常见的一大类秘密分享
叫做线性秘密分享
它通过一个
首先通过一个分享算法
share
把我们要分享的一个秘密
X
它
拆分成
很多个share
Xe xr.xn
给到各个参与方
那么一定数量的参与方
它又可以通过所谓的从购算法
reconstruct
恢复出秘密
那么秘密分享的一个特点是
线性秘密分享它的一个特点是具有加法同态性
因此在对应的NPC协议里面
计算加法操作的时候
只需要进行本地的加法用算
而不需要通信
那么同时
它满足正确性
比如说
任意
t加一个实体
可以恢复出秘密
当然这个t就是它的门限制
那么
同时还有一个安全性或者做隐私性
小于等于t一个实体
任意小于等于t一个实体
它是没有办法
从这个
他们对应的share里面恢复出
他们想要知道的秘密
X
目前NPC常用的
线性秘密分享主要有
主要有四类
现在就是加法秘密分享
这里就是说这个比较简单
就是大家把所有的share
加起来
可这个加可能是一个在一个预算的加法
说也可以是一个退广到一个相量上面
把这些所有的xi的相量加起来
得到了
就得到了原来这个要分享的秘密
那这个是一个比较
简单的一个秘密分享
他通常用于
不诚实大多数的NPC
那么还有那就是
下面下面的秘密分享也是非常常见的
他通常用于诚实大多数的秘密分享
那么实际上下面的秘密分享属于是属于
门线的秘密分享
他
多个
达到门线值的参与方
他可以
通过拉格兰二X值的方法重够秘密
那此外的话
此外的还有那个
复制秘密分享
我们把它叫做replicated secret sharing
他可以把
加法秘密分享
转换成
一般的门线秘密分享
但是呢他的方法比较简单暴力
其实效率不太高
在
在参与方和门线值相对来说是比较小的时候
是比较是可以使用
那最后一个呢是打包秘密分享
他实际上是把多个秘密打包到一个
一个多项势力
那用来平摊
如果在这个多个秘密上
进行同一操作的计算代价
基于秘密分享的方案如何来设计NPC的协议
他的思想其实非常简单
最开始我们通过大家都有输入
我们把自己的输入
通过那个share算法
把这个
各自的这个输入的
分享秘密分享
他对你的份额
分享给其他参与方
接下来就开始进行计算
因为我们在这道电路里面
他可以分为
现性的与门
现性的加法门和非现性的惩罚门
那么这个时候加法门
我们每一个
每一个中间变量他肯定也是
他对你的输出也是需要
分享到
也要也要卸下到各个
他的分享也需要给到各个参与方
那么这个时候因为加法
因为他的同态性
实际上我们计算
x加y
实际上只要只需要各个参与方
把自己对你的share做一个加法就可以了
因为他这个
他的加
他的他这个秘密分享具有加法的同态性
那么做惩罚的话呢
比较复杂一点
他需要通讯
他需要去调用
惩罚的指协议
实现交互的多方计算
那么最后
当我们把这些计算都
完成以后
我们就得到了
其实各个参与方那里
就得到了最后输出的
一个分享
那么大家需要去调用
那个重构算法
reconstruct
来得到最后的结果
那么基于秘密分享的npc协议
他的惩罚的指协议怎么来做
我们这里给出一个简单的例子
假设我们是这是gmw协议里面
假设采用了加法的秘密分享
那么这里的电路是布尔电路
最简单的情况
那么
实际上我们要
用oq来实现
与门的
因为是个
非线性门与门的一个计算
那么这个时候呢
x有两个分享
就是x的两个分享是x0和x1
x0给到了p0 xe给到了p1
那么y的两个分享
是y0和y1
实际上我们要把这个
x0 x1的异货
与上y0和y1的异货
他的值
他的秘密分享给到p0和p1
是吧
那实际上呢
这个可以通过一个
4选1的
oq来实现
刚才我们说了
oq是这样
其实我们前面介绍简单介绍了一个最简单的情况
就有两个消息
发送方有两个消息
接受方从中选一个
那么实际上呢
我们可以用更
更更
更复杂一点的那个
协议
就说他有
这个是一个4选1的oq
4选1的oq的话呢
实际上
右边的这个接收者呢
他可以来做选择
他可以决定自己要选哪一个消息
因为这里面每一个消息
也就对应了
他可以得到的这个
他可以得到的那个share是怎样的
因为我们要
我们可以知道
他最后得到的这个
他最后得到的这个消息呢
re是满足什么呢
r0 异货上re
是等于
x0 异货上re
他的值羽上
y0 异货上y的值
对吧
同时他
x1和y1是他知道的
虽然他不知道
x0和y0
但他
x0和y0不同的值
也就对应了他不同
应该接受到的消息
所以他这个是
他
所以他就可以执行这样一个
oq协议
来得到
4选1的oq协议
他的
惩罚的
惩罚的止协议
那么这里的话呢
其上我们可以有一些
客户的思考
这里用到了一个
4选1的oq协议
那么
那么如果我们
怎样来实现
用二选1的oq协议
来实现这样的一个比特惩罚
并且我们是否可以扩展
gmw的协议
从布尔电路
到环上的一个算数电路
同时呢
我们如何将gmw的协议
扩展到多个参与方
这些都是可以思考的一些问题
那么还有实现承发
止协议的一个长远方法呢
是比特三元组
我们可以计算
这个abc
他这个是这样
他是相关水技术
他在一个预处理阶段
也就是说在我们不知道要计算什么的时候
我们就可以
通过某种协议生成这样的一个三元组
他使得这个
三个水技术
ab他们是相关的
就是c等于ab
我们把这个abc
他们这个share发送到两方
或者说多个参与方
这个时候呢
在在线计算
与
andr运算的时候
实际上我们可以把这个
x1或a和y1或b
这个
这个这个数进行打开发发送在
信号上发送
他不会影响
最后最后的隐私
最最终计算结果的隐私
同时他实现了加法的
加法的计算
计算作为计算的结果实际上
双方就得到了
关于这个他要计算的
x y的
这个
这个惩罚值的一个
秘密分享
这个
这个其实这个方法比较简单
大家可以去看一下
呃另外再基于
小米的秘密分享的这个方案里面
怎么来做惩罚
实际上这里面也非常简单
就是说我们知道
呃秘密值相乘
他实际上就对应了
多相似的相乘
但这里的一个问题是
当我们做惩罚的时候
两个
两个点过力都是t的
多相似相乘
他最后出来的时候
呃
最后成出来
这个多相似他点过力有两
两倍的t
那么这里关键问题是要进行
次数的约解
那么这里就用到可以用到了
ggr
啊
gr的方法
gr的方法是将每个参与方
呃将27的下
27的下
27的一个分享通过t次
多相似
t次的多相似
重新进行分享
然后
通过拉格朗尔细数组合
组合得到最后的
这样一个线
这里的通讯开销是每方
n点一个元素啊
这里的n就是参与方的参与方的个数
那么实际上多个参与方pi
可以计算
由来的现行秘密分享
那么发送给其他参与方
然后通过
范德门的举证
将
由来的分享计算得到
所有参与方对
秘密
秘密职位值的随机分享
i
这里的t次的
现行秘密分享和2t次的
现行秘密分享的这个深层方式是完全
类似的
那么除了多相似的次数有所不同
这里列举了几个工作啊
几个基于下面要惩罚的工作
他们不同的开销啊
每个每次惩罚
每个参与方的通讯开销
继续问意一下
他的开销
当然是大于
计算意义下的安全性
安全性
开销的
这里大家也可以考虑一下如何
使用pr级减少通讯开销
那么实际上他也就
那在使用pr级的同时我们也
得到了
只是计算
计算意义上的安全性
当我们设计出一个
啊半成是安全的npc协议以后
我们可以用通用的方法
编一期的方法
将它转换成
二一级手模型下安全的npc协议
啊那么通用的方法有
gmw编译器
他采用零知识证明协议
用来证明每一步发送消息的合法性
那么还有一种ips编译器
他通过npc in the head的技术
将和两层的npc协议证明我们每一步
实际上实际上就说我证明每一步协议
都是正确执行的
没有偏理
没有恶意的行为在在这里
那么实际上啊
那么通用的编译器的方法
当然他是证明了这个
这个技术的可行性
当我设计出了
半成是的协议
我就可以设计
恶意模型的协议
但实际上他的效率
比较低下
所以在现实中的实际上
对于对于具体的协议
我们可以
具体设计效率更高的
恶意安全的
恶意安全的npc协议
在不诚实大多数的假设下面
比通用编译器更高的方法
更高的当然是实现
恶意安全npc协议的方法
是采用信息
信息论消息认证码的方法
方法来认证他的秘密值
这里我们以spdj协议为例
这里的kai
这个就是希腊字母像一个x一样的
kai表示
kai的加法的秘密分享
在批量打开的过程中
kai i
kai下标i是随机的系数
他通常通过那个call in tossing
就是随机大家共同之音b的协议来生成
那么我们可以验证
求和是否等于0
然后通过对每个值进行承诺
然后打开承诺值
来实现抵抗
抵抗和谋攻击
那批量打开的这里说的是
可以说的是批量打开值的验证
和通讯的开销
实际上是可以忽略的
这使得spdj的协议
在在线通讯效率于gmw协议
基本上是相同的
所以spdj协议
他的效率瓶颈是如何产生认证
和三元组
那么
这个这一类呢
通常他的it就是那个认证的it mic
对吧
那个信息论意义的消息认证
他通常是
通过cot
刚才我们前面就说cot
或者volle协议得到的
那么三元组的计算
通常是通过
运行ot或者olle
这样的一些协议来获得的
那么这里给出了这里几个方法
他的通讯和计算的开销的比较
那么spdj协议他通常是定义在域上的
那么现在呢
也有也有向他扩展到环
就尤其是那个摩奥的K字方这样一个大小的环上的
那么大家可以思考一下
认证三元组协议的构造于域的大小
他们之间有什么关系
前面呢说的是二一大多数
那么实际上在诚实大多数的假设下面
我们可以检测二一行为呢
当前最主要的技术是分布式零知识证明的技术
那么分布式零知识证明呢
实际上是将一个命题x
他通过秘密分享
分享到多个验证者
xcxr到xi
证明者需要将这些验证者证明
命题的合法性
那么同时呢
这里的秘密分享是可以採用下面的秘密分享
我们可以採用Fiat下面的这样一个起发式的假设
实现常数人的惩罚验证
这里当我们引入Fiat下面的这样一个起发式假设以后
我们可以大大降低他们交互的
轮幅达度
我们知道MP的协议他的效率
实际上是随着参与方数的增加增长
尤其是通讯效率等等
那么实际上有些协议他可能有很多很多的参与方
这个时候呢
我们可以有一种方法
比如说他有成百上千的参与方
我们可以通过一种委员会的方法
community的方法
就是说我们随
首先我们这么多人里面
我们现在随即选择
出一部分人
来运行这个
这个协议
但这些人必须要有代表性
所以我们必须这个选择
我们的选择必须随即
不能说我们选出来都是坏人
那么这随即选的时候呢
我们可以有代表性的选出来
一部分好人一部分坏人
那么实际上
这个时候再去
我们把所有的参与方
把自己的数据
分享给
这里面选出来的这个
计算的执行方
那么这个时候呢
我们可以去执行这样的
让这些选出来的
这个委员会的人
来跑一个人数比较少的NPC的协议
最后将
计算结果进行分享
那实际上通过打包秘密分享
打包秘密分享的技术呢
我们可以支持成千上万个
参与方的NPC的
这样一个大型的NPC的协议
最后我们总结一下
多方安全计算技术
并进行一个展望
最后安全多方计算
实际上它有很多的应用
前面已经说了一类重要的应用
就是隐私保护的机器学习
包括机器学习的模型训练
模型预测以及模型外包服
我们用它来保护模型参数的隐私
保护客户数据的隐私
实际上这里面
安全多方计算它可以做任意的计算
所以这些计算当然也包括了
机器学习的这一类应用
此外还有一些分布式的密要管理
我们将一个私要可以
区块链里面
比如说一个签名的私要
一个账户的私要可以分享到
多个人
一个委员会里的多个人
这样的话就可以保护密要的安全性
因为有些人如果丢了私要
其实整体上是不影响私要的安全性
同时我们可以用它来抵抗
针对私要的其他的一些攻击
比如说侧性道攻击等等
安全多方计算它可以有不同的方法
来实现
比如混淆电路和秘密分享
它们各自有利弊
比如说混淆电路需要占用交道的贷款
但是它通讯轮数是常数轮
所以它是用在延时较高的一些
它可以在延时较高的一些网络中
展现它的优势
那么秘密分享的方法
它占用贷款比较少
但是它的交互比较频繁
轮数比较多
它与电路的深度成正比
所以它比较适用于在低延时的网络当中
那么同时我们可以将多方计算
它的抵手分为城市大多数和非城市大多数
并且抵手的恶意行为也可以
分为半城市的提手和恶意的抵手
这个时候我们可以用到了不同的混淆电路的构造
也可能用到了不同的电路的认证方法
那么我们可以采用
根据它城市大多数
还是不城市大多数
我们可以采用不同的秘密分享的方法
同时为了对抗恶意抵手
根据它的恶意抵手的占比
我们可以采用不同的
比如说是认证的混淆电路的方法
还是分布临时式证明的方法等等
来实现最优的一些安全东方计算的设计
那么接下来做一些展望
实际上我们知道安全东方计算
它与同态加密不一样
全国加密不一样的地方是安全东方计算的
主要的效率平顶它是通讯而不是计算
那么我们也看到
现实中很多安全东方计算的协议
它的性能是在不断提高的
并且它与明文计算的性能
已经开始
之前的差距已经开始不断缩小
甚至部分的协议
它的恶意抵手模型下的通讯协议效率
已经达到后的接近
半成是模型下的协议的效率
当然这是个别情况
那么同时我们也看到
实际上在游戏赛业混淆电路里面
每一个雨门
它加密以后的通讯
11.5个安全参数
我们就目前来说能做到最好的
那么如何突破这个下界
目前来说是负面的
基本上很难突破
并且我们已经看到了一些负面的结果
同时我们也见到了
不少的恶意的安全模型的下面的
安全通方计算的协议
它并半成是模型下
它要慢很多
那么这个性能的问题如何去突破
同时在这个协议实际上
NPC它的发展仍然是非常快的
有不断
有不断不断有新的协议出来
那么如何来做标准化
这个也是我们需要思考的一个
一个课题
非常感谢大家的宝贵时间
谢谢大家